hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Gothic mystery
thriller film called the pale blue eye
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie is set in the year 1830 in the
Hudson Valley region of New York the
protagonist is a retired detective
Augustus Landor he lives alone in his
house and does nothing but drink this is
because his wife passed away due to an
illness some years ago and his daughter
has been missing for months one morning
as he is chilling by the river a
military officer Captain Hitchcock
approaches him and mentions that his
senior wants to meet him Landor who
doesn't like leaving his house refuses
to go but when Hitchcock stresses that
the matter is urgent he agrees along the
way they talk about landor's past
achievements it turns out that he is one
of the best detectives in the country
with a 100 success rate he has always
solved the mystery he has been assigned
to even the ones in Gotham City soon
they arrive at a military academy and
head straight into superintendent
Thayer's office the latter knows Landor
so well that he is aware of his wife's
death and his daughter's disappearance
after expressing his condolences he gets
straight to the point and reveals that
one of their military soldiers was found
dead the soldier was from Kentucky his
name was fry and his favorite food was
chicken everyone suspects that he
committed the unthinkable but a few
things suggest otherwise someone
approached fry after his death cut open
his body with precision and removed his
heart after explaining all this they are
requests land or find the culprit and
bring him to light the detective agrees
and immediately gets to work he along
with Hitchcock visit the morgue and meet
with Dr Daniel the same doctor who
conducted Fry's autopsy Daniel mentions
that he has already checked the corpse
thoroughly but couldn't find anything
suspicious however when Landor performs
a basic checkup he finds a bruise behind
Fry's head and a torn piece of paper in
his hand this makes him conclude that
fry didn't commit the unthinkable but
someone killed him on purpose Landor
tries his best to decipher the meaning
in the torn piece of paper but to no
avail only a few words are written and
guessing the exact sentence is near
impossible before he leaves the academy
Hitchcock warns him to keep the ongoing
investigation a secret later Landor
visits the place where Fry's body was
found and starts investigating right
then a Cadet named Edgar Allan Poe
approaches him and says that he believes
fry was killed by a poet that's not Poe
that's Dudley dursley fry was killed by
a dementor Case Closed Poe believes that
fry was killed by a poet because he
himself is a poet who is aware of the
art of extracting someone's heart from
their body Landor obviously does not
believe in this so Edgar gives him
another clue he says that a few days
before fry was killed he had a fight
with his roommate in the next scene
Landor heads to the academy and
interrogates a few Cadets with the
permission of Hitchcock however none of
them State anything that can help with
the case after the interrogation ends an
officer arrives there with a note for
Hitchcock the latter reads it and is
taken aback it turns out that a cow and
a sheep have been killed in similar
fashion their hearts have been taken out
after strangling them to death it is
evident that the Killer is warning them
to stop the investigation however this
only makes a land or more focused on
finding the killer so he heads straight
to Edgar and asks him to help decipher
the message written on the piece of
paper he found in Fry's hand although
Edgar is only a trainee who is not
allowed to interact with Outsiders he
agrees to help and surprisingly the same
evening he comes up with an answer he
visits Landor at his house and explains
that although he cannot say what the
entire note said the last paragraph
mentions don't be light this means that
the killer had invited fry to a location
after a bit of discussion the two come
to the conclusion that the note was
written by a woman this is because a
Cadet like fry would have no purpose
meeting a man outside late at night just
then Edgar remembers seeing a beautiful
woman outside the military base on the
day the murder was committed the
following day Landor sends a note to
Edgar asking him to meet him at an Ice
House near Lake courage without wasting
any time Edgar arrives there and finds
Landor inspecting an old abandoned house
inside he know this is a circle and a
triangle drawn on the floor and assumes
that someone and conducted a ritual
there he also mentions that the
performers placed Fry's heart in between
the shapes and performed black magic as
the house belongs to the doctor Daniel's
son Artemis Landor now suspects that
Artemis did all of this however to learn
more about black magic he takes Edgar to
meet one of his special friends Jon who
is an expert in such topics they provide
him with diagrams of the strange shapes
and Jon immediately deduces that it is a
special kind of Black Magic Ritual
performed to become immortal he also
mentions that to conduct it one needs
the heart of an unbaptized child and one
of a man who died from hanging hearing
all of this Landor asks Edgar to
befriend Artemis and try to extract more
information from him the cadet agrees
and starts meeting Artemis on a regular
basis surprisingly they become good
friends one night Edgar gathers with
Artemis and his friends for some drinks
from their conversation he learns that
fry was in a relationship with artemis's
beautiful sister Leah many believe that
he committed the unthinkable after after
she ditched him elsewhere Landor gets a
vision of his lost daughter and starts
panicking it is clear that he still
hasn't gotten over the tragedy the next
morning the murdered cadet's funeral is
finally conducted as Landor Pays His
respects he is approached by Fry's
mother who hands him Fry's diary she
wants him to have it so that he can find
the real culprit she also mentions that
everything in the diary is written in a
cryptographic language and she does not
understand any of it later while
returning home Landor runs into Daniel
and his wife Wiley and tells them that
he will not stop until he finds the
Killer and punishes him when Wiley asks
him about his wife Landor replies to her
that she died two years ago land or may
be starved for answers but Wiley is the
one that is obviously thirsty elsewhere
Edgar goes to artemis's house to find
out more about him but he is immediately
distracted when he hears Leah playing
the piano since she also loves poetry
the two get to talking and become
attracted to one another before he
leaves Edgar invites Leah to meet him at
outside the following day to which she
agrees in the next scene the two meet at
a cemetery hot date and begin expressing
their feelings Edgar states that he is
greatly attracted by her beauty and her
charm when it's Leah's turn she
unexpectedly suffers from a seizure and
falls to the ground luckily she soon
recovers and Edgar accompanies her back
home meanwhile Landor tears out the
papers from Fry's Personal Diary and
successfully extracts some information
from it at night as Edgar is working
alone a fellow Cadet and artemis's
friend Ballinger attacks him from behind
and beats him up badly fortunately
Landor arrives there in the nick of time
and saves Edgar before he is killed the
next day Landor gets to know that
Ballinger is missing and later finds his
body hanging in the woods with his heart
removed however this time Daniel takes a
closer look at Ballinger's body and
reveals that the person who removed his
heart is different from the one in Fry's
case The Cutting is not as precise or
accurate this time hearing this the
high-ranking officials get angry and
they ask land or to solve the case as
soon as possible for starters they want
him to interrogate Edgar as he is the
most mysterious and cunning person at
the camp when Lindor refuses to comply
Hitchcock reveals that Edgar recently
fought with both murder victims fry and
Ballinger this surprises Landor as his
Poet Buddy had never mentioned any of
this so he meets Edgar outside and asks
if he's hiding something the latter
confirms to have fought with them
because they constantly bullied him for
his appearance and his habits however he
didn't kill them Edgar explains that if
he were to kill everyone he had a
problem with there would be less than a
dozen Cadets left seeing his innocent
and frankly strange face Landor is
convinced so he walks away without
asking anything more one night the two
were invited to Daniel's place for
dinner which they accept while they are
eating Landor finds Wiley very anxious
and scared as if she is hiding something
after dinner he talks to Daniel
privately and inquires if something is
wrong with his daughter the doctor
reveals that Leah is suffering from a
rare disorder that gives her frequent
seizure sad thing is that there is no
cure for it right then Hitchcock arrives
and informs them that another Cadet
Stoddard is missing this alarms Landor
so he immediately goes to check the
cadet's personal room they do not find
anything there so Landor suspects that
Stoddard got involved in some shady
business alongside fry and Ballinger and
that's why they are being hunted but
since his body hasn't been found it is
possible that he has simply run away
following this Landor goes to his wizard
friend John and asks him about the witch
hunter that he mentioned before Jon
brings out a picture of it explaining
that he is the one who wrote the book
containing the procedures to become
immortal as soon as Landor sees the
picture he remembers seeing it at
Daniel's house and immediately heads
over there meanwhile Leah and Artemis
have captured Edgar and are about to
perform the same ritual as they did with
Fry's heart shortly after Lander arrives
at Daniel's house and confronts him
about the Witch Hunter and his
daughter's illness having been caught
red-handed the doctor accepts his
mistake and reveals that after he failed
to treat his daughter he was forced to
follow the path of witch hunting to keep
Leah alive however he mentions that his
wife daughter and his son are mainly
involved in the process even now they
are about to sacrifice Edgar for the
cause hearing this Landor becomes
terrified and rushes towards the
abandoned house fortunately he reaches
there in the nick of time right before
Aaliyah and Artemis can cut through
Edgar while Landor is relieved Leah
becomes enraged and starts spilling oil
everywhere igniting a large fire Artemis
uses this opportunity to fight Landor so
that his sister can continue the ritual
but sadly while she is at it a large
wooden pole falls on her knocking her
unconscious Artemis rushes to save her
but both of them get trapped in the fire
before the entire Cottage collapses
Landor grabs Wiley and Edgar and leaves
the place the following day with Edgar
in the hospital the superintendent
officer Praises Landor for his service
believing that the case has finally been
solved Hitchcock also thanks Landor and
apologizes for misbehaving with them at
times Case Closed just kidding this
movie has a 45 minute epilogue let's go
after a few weeks have passed Edgar
completely recovers and visits Landor at
his house surprisingly he has found out
something shocking he mentions that
after examining the handwriting on the
Note fragment in Fry's possession and on
the note that he received from Landor he
found that they were identical by
connecting all the dots and the evidence
he has obtained it is clear that Landor
was responsible for the cadet's deaths
Edgar then presents his findings and
tells Landor that from a lady at the
tavern he got to know about his daughter
matilde this is when Landor accepts his
crimes and finally reveals everything it
turns out that two years prior after
attending her first ball dance party
matild was returning home alone when she
was violated by fry Ballinger and
Stoddard although she survived the
incident traumatized her so badly that
she committed the unthinkable from a
cliff Landor witnessed the entire
incident and tried his best to stop her
but to no avail as the days passed by
Landor hid this information from
everyone and lied that she had fled but
because matild suffered and died right
in front of his eyes he wanted to take
revenge so he approached fry lured him
with a message and took him to a
deserted area there he brutally finished
him off and made this scene look as if
the victim had committed the unthinkable
after he left Leia and Artemis extracted
Fry's heart for their ritual when Edgar
asks him how he found out about
Ballinger Landor replies that he got to
know from Fry's Personal Diary so at the
opportune moment he murdered Ballinger
and dismembered his body to give the
impression that the cadet had been
killed by the same killer who disfigured
Fry's body this is the reason why Dr
Daniel found both incisions to be
different finally Landor believes that
Stoddard had run away due to the fear of
being killed he might have escaped but
we'll have to live out the rest of his
life in fear Landor took part in the
investigation because he didn't want
anyone to suspect him he also wanted to
know who extracted Fry's heart in the
final scene Landor tells Edgar that he
can go and tell the authorities that he
is the real killer however the poet
refuses saying what he did was
understandable criminals like fry and
Ballinger deserve nothing less than what
they got saying this Edgar burns the
notes and hence a race is the evidence
that could have gotten the detective
arrested Edgar then leaves but not
before telling Landor that he really
Treasures the moments they spent
together I'll never thought I'd get to
meet Batman
the movie ends with Landor walking to
the edge of the same Cliff from where
his daughter committed the unthinkable
he lets her hair ribbon float away
saying rest my love
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching